this video is sponsored by Ray Khan get
15% off their already affordable
wireless earbuds with the link in the
description February 29th
2020 the day of the first coronavirus
death in the United States reported at
the time the day for Americans that this
mysterious highly infectious disease
went from distant news story to actual
alarming reality from the date of that
first reported death it would take less
than one month for the u.s. to become
the most infected country in the world
passing Italy than China and eventually
ending up in a category of its own but
although the outbreak was real
everywhere it was felt viscerally in the
Northeast one of only a handful of
places in the country where headlines of
despair seemed to match the daily
experience of locals there were not only
two waves but effectively two distinct
pandemics for those in and around New
York the corona virus was all too
horrifyingly real creating a more
vigilant atmosphere even now as new
local cases stabilize masks are widely
worn hands frequently washed and public
spaces treated with caution outside of
the Northeast Corridor a very different
pandemic played out one with the first
casualties or jobs classes and the
conveniences of modern life reactions to
government imposed restrictions were so
geographically divided in part because
the corona virus was so geographically
divided now as infections surged across
the country a once regional crisis is
becoming a shared disaster everyone
everywhere is in some way affected by
the virus but it would be a mistake to
say that everyone is affected equally
just as in the early days of the
pandemic there are broadly speaking two
very different groups of people those
who've lost work school and their
livelihoods and those who can treat lock
down as a vacation generally speaking
this
is an exceptionally great time to be
rich and an exceptionally bad time to be
poor since March around 50 million
people have filed for unemployment
setting records not seen since the Great
Depression meanwhile the country's
richest have seen their wealth explode
during that same period the net worth of
US billionaires has grown by almost 20
percent and a dozen in particular have
doubled their wealth when most Americans
were stuck in their hometowns if not
their living rooms the richest among us
now untethered geographically by work
school and friends were on the move to
their vacation homes in Jackson Hole
Nantucket and Sun Valley they're in
these small remote towns wealthy
families brought from their big cities
the risk of infection Teton County for
example of which Jackson Hole is a part
of is one of the richest counties in the
country home at least during ski season
of Bill Gates Kanye West Christy Walton
and Dick Cheney to name just a few
it's one in only hospital equipped with
just 24 ventilators was put to the test
as private jets swarmed local airports
despite being home to just 23,000
full-time residents Teton was Wyoming's
second hardest hit County in April
surpassing other areas three or four
times more populous until the second
wave hit other wealthy families booked
out entire hotels or resorts for twenty
thirty or forty thousand dollars a week
finally some went even further
preferring to leave the country
altogether private jet companies were
inundated with requests both from a lack
of available scheduled flights and a
concern for health and safety one study
suggests regular passenger air travel
involves 270 person-to-person
interactions while private flights
expose a customer to less than 20 but
while demand for a safe place to hide is
clearly very high it's far harder to
find supply pandemic tourists as you
might call them are looking for three
things some place Karuna via
is under control somewhere that is
isolated and likely to avoid further
outbreaks and of course somewhere that
will let them in the trouble is that any
country which meets the first two
criteria likely did so by avoiding the
third in other words any place where
outbreaks are contained likely closed
its borders early and is unwilling to
undo it's hard work now this rules out
the vast majority of countries Italy for
instance denied entry to five US
citizens who flew from Colorado earlier
this month on a private jet the risk of
allowing them in despite their riches is
just too high but not everywhere there
are a few countries where the benefits
of tourism are so insanely high as to
outweigh the risk of further outbreaks
these are mostly small island nations
like Fiji the Bahamas and the Maldives
for the latter country Travel and
Tourism comprise nearly 40 percent of
its GDP these are places that can't
afford to lose visitors but with limited
health care infrastructure they really
can't afford an outbreak and therefore
had to take the lesser of two very bad
evils take the case of Fiji its borders
were first closed on February 3rd weeks
before the first confirmed case to any
foreigner who had visited mainland China
in the past 14 days in addition to
screening the health of passengers
during their flights to Fiji
on the 27th this ban was extended to all
travelers from Italy Iran and parts of
South Korea 18 days later cruise ship
stops international events and
government travel were also canceled
three days after that Fiji confirmed its
first case a Fiji Airways flight
attendant who had recently flown to San
Francisco and Oakland after this first
person began a chain of community
transmission infecting four others
locals expected the worst in early March
it became the first Pacific island
country to open a who certified testing
lab and the fourth Pacific country
capable of testing for Cova
19 this enabled instant results rather
than waiting for samples to be sent to
Australia by the end of the month its
main International Airport was closed
any military enforced curfew announced
from 10:00 p.m. to 5:00 a.m. then an
amazing 78 days went by between its 18th
and 19th cases as of early July 2020
despite a population of 880 3,000 spread
across 300 Islands Fiji has recorded a
total of 21 infections making it
possible to list every past and present
case in a single frame it's also managed
a 100 percent recovery rate with the
vast majority of recent cases coming
from returning locals staying in
quarantine in this way Fiji perfectly
encapsulates the dilemma of countries
like it having made early and painful
sacrifices to prevent an outbreak they
now have a new kind of vacation amenity
being free of coronavirus that they're
eager to reap the benefits from but at
the risk of making things much much
worse every country island and city
depends on tourism to a different degree
and thus every country island and city
has responded differently Cuba for
example has divided the country such
that visitors stay only in designated
resort areas and don't in fact the
general population Hawaii on the other
hand will allow travelers to skip its
mandatory two-week quarantine if they
present a negative test result 72 hours
before arrival Fiji like several other
countries has come to a different
conclusion it knows that the risk of
welcoming visitors is directly
proportional to the number who arrived
but the number of visitors is not
necessarily proportional to the benefits
they bring they can minimize the risk of
reopening while maximizing the income
they generate by inviting only the rich
to quantify this fact Australia is the
largest source of arrivals and Fiji
accounting for just under half of the
total they spend on average 100
sixteen US dollars per person per day
and one thousand thirty nine dollars per
trip a cruise ship passenger in
comparison spends forty four dollars on
average per port of call
and finally someone arriving by yacht
spends three thousand six hundred and
fifteen dollars during their average
stay in total the yachting industry
contributes approximately twenty eight
million dollars to the Fijian economy
every year not that far behind the forty
four million
brought by the cruise industry cruise
ships expose the islands to two hundred
and thirty nine thousand passengers a
year while yachts expose them to just
four thousand four hundred and
seventy-three by comparing these numbers
we can very crudely estimate that yachts
bring approximately two percent the risk
of infection that cruise ships do while
contributing sixty three percent as much
to the local economy this is the
thinking behind Fiji's new blue lanes
program which allows billionaires to
bypass its coronavirus border
restrictions its prime minister
announced that yachts and pleasure craft
will now be allowed to enter one of its
ports if a ship's journey there took 14
days or longer at sea and its passengers
show proof of a negative test result
everyone on board will be screened for
symptoms and if deemed healthy enough
allowed to roam the country if their
journey was shorter they can make up the
remaining time in quarantine
if someone arrives from Sydney after
eight days at sea for example they can
pay for six days of quarantine and then
proceed to hide out on a remote private
island and Fiji is not alone many
countries are competing for the VIP
crowd Seychelles is also allowing
visitors who arrive on private or
chartered flights and then stay on an
isolated island resort Thailand the
Maldives and other countries have
similar plans in all likelihood only a
very small number of billionaires will
arrive so far Fiji has announced 30 but
that is precisely the goal to cash in on
their strong early pandemic response
while inviting very little additional
if it works International Travel may
slowly revert to the status it once held
decades ago reserved mostly for the rich
and fairly inaccessible to everyone else
one thing that is getting much more
affordable are wireless earbuds recon
sent me a pair of their everyday model
and I've been wearing them every week at
the gym since they start at just about
half the price of other wireless earbuds
help block out the noise around you and
last up to six hours on a charge I've
used other wireless earbuds before and I
was pleasantly surprised by how durable
ray cons are although not exactly
recommended I've even heard of them
surviving accidental trips to the
washing machine they won't fall out of
your ears because they come with five
extra different size tips plus you can
even choose from a selection of six
colors to truly make them your own get
15% off with the link in the description
and my thanks to recon for sponsoring
this video